what if I told you that the people who
made Your Dragon Ball Z DVDs suck at
their job and more than that they
freaking lied to you over the past 20
years there have been so many different
re-releases of Dragon Ball on DVD
Blu-ray and whatever that you could fill
in library with them and still not fit
them all this show has been sold in so
many different ways and the number one
question is always which one is the best
the answer no okay well that's not
exactly right unfortunately if there was
an easy answer to that this video would
be 15 seconds long and I wouldn't feel
the need to punch a war on the thought
of having to break this all down because
sadly the honest answer is actually 99
of them are completely terrible in one
way or another and believe it or not
that does include the Beloved Dragon Box
that fans have coveted for so many years
so buckle up because we are going
through all the major English releases
and breaking down the nitty-gritty
details of what works what doesn't work
and by the end you'll be just as mad
about everything as I am
ha ha ha
okay so before we dive in I want to
preface this by acknowledging that some
people just want to own the show and I
imagine many of you already do it sucks
to learn something you've spent money on
isn't great especially if you never
realized that in the first place but
this isn't an attack on you it's an
exploration of how this Series has been
mistreated over the years and why we
should continue to demand better and hey
if you get to the end of this video and
you still don't care just know that you
made blurry Android 16 cry and you must
now live with your sins up first we are
heading back to the simpler time of the
late 1990s with what's known as the DBZ
singles these bad boys were funimation's
first attempt at releasing the series on
DVD and in spite of their age they're
actually not half bad you see all three
Dragon Ball series were created using
cells by which I mean the animators
drawings were traced or scanned onto a
transparent sheet and then carefully
painted these were then photographed
wrapped onto film to produce the final
animation the big benefit of film is you
can keep scanning it into higher
resolutions despite its age but
unfortunately the film is unstable and
ages quickly if not stored properly
Dragon Ball is Mega cursed and its
colors have died a death over the years
which is definitely something you'll see
in other releases the DBZ singles
however come from a tape Master created
before this film degradation began so on
the color side of things these are
actually surprisingly faithful to the
color design of the show the skies are
actually blue the skin tones are neutral
for the most part it does look okay
enough while there are definitely
stretches where colors don't look so
great or the dark details are kinda
crushed I think where this one falls on
the most is in its actual video quality
this is an old DVD so it's kind of
crunchy and things will fall apart
during a lot of movement and with it
being sourced from a tape you also have
to deal with things like rainbows on the
lines with nasty alias missing this
release was initially censored for the
first few volumes but Was Then followed
up by the ultimate uncut addition which
is almost identical other than being a
little less crunchy except now you're
free of that evil censorship business if
you're someone who loves the original
FUNimation dub and wants to own it in a
form that's reasonably close to its
original broadcast then these are for
you they're about a B plus in color a c
minus in visual Fidelity maybe a c plus
in audio and well unfortunately for you
they're an F in availability because
they are long out of print next up we
have oh
oh no
it's the dreaded the orange bricks yeah
where do I even begin with these so you
know how FUNimation we're releasing the
series uncut with reasonable colors and
its original aspect ratio yeah so they
scrapped those a few volumes in and
decided that actually no what you need
is their anti-quote it's originally
intended unaltered State Edition chances
are you've at least seen these on
shelves before if not actually heard
about how incredibly terrible they are
these were everywhere and very quickly
became the most sold version of the
series in the west thanks to how cheap
and easily available they were
Unfortunately they get just about
everything wrong that you could possibly
get wrong when remastering video the
first sin here is in the cropping with
Dragon Ball Z being a TV show from 1989
to 1996 it was of course storyboarded
and animated for the shape of TVs at the
time a squarish aspect ratio called 4x3
it was always intended to be seen this
way and yet FUNimation decided that
because TVs had moved to widescreen they
would just zoom in and crop 20 of the
image off to make it fit so now you're
constantly losing the top and bottom of
people's faces often completely removing
their mouths or ruining shots that
specifically use that space in a
creative way remember a couple of years
ago when everyone was in an uproar
because streaming services were Zoom
cropping old TV shows which resulted in
stuff like this or this well surprise
because FUNimation was here cropping
footage out of existence before it was
even cool I understand that a small
minority of people don't like black
buyers on their 16x9 TVs when watching
4x3 content but I think these companies
forget that people can just zoom in with
their remote like people who want to
watch it as intended can zoom out stuff
you straight up removed man and next up
on the orange bricks is the Abomination
they made of the colors
for some insane reason FUNimation
boosted the ever-loving hell out of the
contrast and saturation for these
releases and as a result it now looks
like ten shinhan took a solar flare to
most of the show anything that's even
remotely bright is now blown out
completely eradicating any and all
detail the worst part is that it doesn't
end there like I mentioned earlier the
three Dragon Ball series were all
produced on film and part of said film
is green it's an aspect intrinsic to the
format and in fact in live action
cinematographers and directors will
carefully pick out film stock based on
how its colors and grain look as a
result removing grain from live action
is a complete sin and leads to horrific
looking wax monsters with animation
there's a little more leeway and there
are two schools of thought here you can
go for a filmic approach and leave the
green intact which is something you can
see on a release like Cowboy Bebop for
example on the flip side you can
carefully remove the Grain and produce
something that looks like an animation
Cell come to life such as Cardcaptor
Sakura both are valid but both need to
be done correctly unfortunately
FUNimation went with scrubbing the Grain
and then did it terribly their cleanup
is so bad in fact that their dust and
scratch filtering actively removes lines
throughout the series like
so 20 of the image now gone shading
blown out and the lines partially
removed preposterously that's getting an
F for visual Fidelity and a D minus for
color if only because the Buu Arc is
actually not half bad by the time you
trudge your way through the disaster
piece that were the prior three arcs on
the bright side the orange bricks did at
least finally introduce a new audio
track that allowed fans to watch the
English dub with the original Japanese
score the falconer scores also there and
both tracks have sections of their poor
early voice acting redubbed so yay I
guess have a B for audio I don't know I
and well reluctantly I'll give this also
an A plus for availability because these
things just won't go away now let's take
a deep breath regain our composure from
the traumatic experience we just endured
and give ourselves a little Whiplash as
we are heading straight into a fan
favorite it is of course time for the
dragon boxes these bad boys originally
came out in Japan in 2003 and then
finally made their way to the US in 2009
at the time it was like the heavens had
opened and our prayers had finally been
answered the original 4x3 aspect ratio
grain fully intact a fresh scan from
toys original Masters next episode
previews and Japanese title cards to
boot it has everything people had been
asking for and to this day it is widely
considered the best way to watch the
series but as we've already established
no Dragon Ball release is perfect and
unfortunately these came with two very
big sins SIN number one their colors are
terrible while FUNimation did too much
to their release toei did too little and
by too little I mean literally nothing
remember how I said film degrades over
time well Dragon Ball's Masters degraded
awfully and that means the colors have
dramatically warped over time so blue
skies have turned teal orange geese have
turned red skin tones have often shifted
super pink and in some of the worst
cases the image has started to lose huge
amounts of detail in spite of everything
it does right the release is painfully
married by the show's original color
design dying in absolute death at the
hands of film rot and alas that's not
all the dragon Box's second sin comes in
the form of its audio while the Japanese
audio track on every release mentioned
so far sounds like you're listening to
it through a speaker stuffed inside a
pillowcase the cause of which I'll touch
on later the actual audio sync here is
off you'll be hearing everything
slightly too late which isn't quite as
distracting as it sounds but once you
notice it it's impossible to ignore of
course the true pain here is that
despite being almost great this is
another release that FUNimation no
longer prints so it is nearly impossible
to find racking up nearly three hundred
dollars per set second hand online I
wish I was joking I mean seriously 300
second hand online die overall this
thing May well get an A for its Fidelity
but with a pretty lackluster C minus in
color and audio and an F in availability
it's just impossible to recommend this
to anyone who doesn't already have it
jumping forward a little to 2011 and now
FUNimation is back at it again with a
brand new remaster in the form of the
level sets after an agonizing orange
bricks disaster this release was truly
the second coming of Home Video Jesus
Not only was this drag Dragon Ball Z's
first Native HD scan but FUNimation
really put effort into this thing by
their standards the grain management was
super light there was a reasonable color
correction attempt and unlike the dragon
boxes that removed the falconer score
this had everything for every type of
fan on paper this looked to be the
answer to our prayers but of course
Dragon Ball is cursed so there had to be
a catch in well there were several the
source for this new HD scan was
funimation's own material which is
actually a multi-gen master what that
means is that it's a copy of the
original toei film materials think of it
like a film photocopy and well this new
release is the equivalent of a photocopy
of a photocopy I'm sure you could
imagine that's not ideal and as a result
this thing is extra grainy and the
detail in the dark areas is mostly
missing the overall colors are also
quite muted and well the team were
clearly far too afraid of repeating the
orange bricks that they simply didn't do
enough to restore this into something
genuinely stunning the thing is I think
almost everyone was willing to overlook
these flaws because at least in the main
areas such as Clarity it largely still
felt like a step up over what had come
before unfortunately these sets were
expensive and with FUNimation selling so
many Dragon Ball DVDs and Blu-rays at
this point people just did not buy these
ones and so they were canceled only two
sets in in spite of sitting at a high B
across the board it's F in availability
makes it get another close but no cigar
moment for Dragon Ball home releases
believe it or not we have only two
releases left so let's get to it and
talk about the Blu-ray season sets
released a measly two years after the
level sets FUNimation decided to play a
cruel trick in everyone in the lead up
to this release they put out a survey
asking fans if they'd like the next
release to be 4x3 or 16x9 there was
radio silence and then suddenly this new
set dropped and it was orange bricks 2.0
time it was cropped the colors were
obliterated and the degrading was
astonishingly awful oh no we all thought
the Casual viewers must have voted for
16.9 in the poll uh nope turns out 4x3
had overwhelmingly won and yet
FUNimation ignored it internally because
the orange bricks had sold the most so
in other words rather than the lesson
being cheap box sets make good sale it
was no grain and color make money go
Burr it's hard to overstay just how
terrible this release is there's a
number of people who believe this to be
better than the orange bricks because it
isn't quite as blown out and the
degrading isn't making lines disappear
in quite so obvious of fashion and
that's definitely valid but actually
this thing is just as bad if not worse
in many areas despite claims they
manually cropped it to 16x9 this time
rather than just doing an automated
Center crop it is very often and cropped
far more poorly than having just left it
in the center in the first place and yet
that's actually the least of its issues
the grain removal is back in full force
and while it isn't deleting lines what
it is doing is barely functioning
properly so in other words it's blurring
the ever-loving life out of the lines
and the grain is still trying to creep
back in leading to the entire image
wobbling constantly around any hard Edge
worse still they've then tried to
sharpen it to death making the entire
image look like a flat watery mess this
thing is so bad that it genuinely has
worse Clarity in areas than its DVD
predecessors and also I've not even
mentioned how horribly oversaturated the
colors are everyone either looks like a
lobster or like they've not seen sun in
a thousand years there's no in between
here just geez shame on FUNimation for
this one F in colors F in visual
Fidelity B in audio just by virtue of
having everything and once again because
FUNimation is cruel it actively hates us
it gets a solid a plus in availability
and so we reached the end of this
nightmare see
spy with FUNimation content to sell
these nasty Blu-rays to all who are
interested until finally for the series
30th Anniversary they decided to rise
once again and do a limited collector's
edition remaster of the series a
definitive release they said one geared
towards the most hardcore fans of the
series so how did this collector's 30th
Anniversary set fair
yeah
yeah yeah
yes folks it turns out this definitive
collection that they tried to crowdfund
by the way was almost literally
identical to the previous set surely
there are some changes you might be
asking and you 'd be right they removed
the cropping and uh
added a fake layer of grain
is that really is now I don't want to
let one of those go by unnoticed that's
right rather than do a legitimate
faithful remaster they pulled up their
old one that everyone hated remove the
crop and then stuck an artificial layer
of grain over the top in the most
hilariously half-assed attempt I've ever
seen I really truly wish I was making
this up of course fans were Furious and
so they released a damage control blog
post that only made things worse they
showed off their untouched Masters next
to the abomination in one of the biggest
middle fingers in recent memory
hilariously this limited release didn't
even meet its sales goals and they then
package it up in a bunch of Steel books
you can now buy everywhere it gets the
exact same rating as the last release
with the most pitiful thumbs up for at
least removing the cropping I guess what
hurts so much is that this video only
encompasses the Z part of the series
I've not had time to talk about the
original series and how it's most
available release is tightly cropped and
poorly encoded I've not been able to
touch on how every GT release is so red
tinted that it's convinced the worldwide
fandom that GT looks as red as a British
tourist in Spain I've had no time to
praise the first few arcs of Kai for
their near accurate color work in spite
of its overly blurry Clarity and
distracting redraws I've not even been
able to scream about the final chapter's
green tint and cropped Abomination
Dragon Ball's home releases Encompass
two decades worth of suffering and I
hope this video in spite of its brevity
has opened your eyes to how poorly such
an iconic Series has been treated all of
this time it really is just bad the
whole way down but there is a ray of
Hope a tiny possibility for a brighter
future Looms on the horizon for deep in
the jungles of an unknown region of this
world known as far as an actual
competent release of this series is
starting to make its presence felt and
if it does well enough who knows maybe
its footage could make its way into the
hands of a newly fused crunchy nation
and we could be graced with its Glory
let me introduce you to the ab group
blue rays
talking about these is technically
cheating because they are only available
in France don't even have English
subtitles much less an English dub and
they haven't even started on Dragon Ball
Z itself yet but last year a French
company by the name of a b group started
putting out a new remaster of Dragon
Ball on Blu-ray and the results well
they're kind of nuts guys just about
everything that could go right they did
do right the colors are manually
corrected to be far more faithful than
any prior release the visual Fidelity is
fantastic thanks to a groundbreaking
upscale of the Dragon Box footage
retaining all original elements such as
the fine film grain and aspect ratio and
perhaps most critically the audio this
is genuinely the first a plus audio to
ever be released in the entire world I
mentioned earlier the Japanese dragon
ball always sounds incredibly muffled
which people often attribute to the age
of the show when in actuality it's
because every release before it has been
using an aged format of it this release
makes use of the original audio that was
once thought to be lost but was then
found and compiled by fans and finally
gives us those original Japanese
performances with the pristine Clarity
it deserves
it is crazy how good it feels to hear
things so clearly to see the whole image
with the colors and crispness that was
intended all this time and while like I
said it is currently only released in
France the sets themselves are 100
easily available not a limited release
and are priced ridiculously affordably
this set is a plus across the board and
maybe just maybe a b group can partner
with the English rights holders at some
point and get this incredible release
into the hands of English-speaking fans
across the world because as I've just
spent this video painfully explaining
Dragon Ball fans have had it rough we've
had it rough for a long long time and
despite being one of the most popular
anime in the history of the planet there
is still not a single release I can
reliably recommend to anyone which just
boggles my mind until another release
surfaces from the depths of Hell in the
future this video will stand as the
complete guide to all English home
releases of Dragon Ball Z and hopefully
by now you have a bit better of an
understanding as to why Dragon Ball Z is
known as a curse series when it comes to
DVD and Blu-ray releases unless a
miracle happens and that a b group
release makes its way to America we will
all just have to pray to Kami that we
will one day be graced with a
non-compromised release of this show we
all hold so near and dear to our hearts
until then I'll keep watching it
whatever way I can I've been totally not
Mark thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign